how do you feel about your country we
just had the Fourth of July some people
don't like their country very much
people like the singer Jill Scott
that this place face doesn't surmise
[Music]
on you colored
child
whose blood okay I think we get what
it's bloody the blood built this land
and the white people are evil and the
black people did all the good stuff and
they're always pressed and okay whatever
here's the attention you ordered ma'am
here you are
do you want it here can I or give you
some attention hors d'oeuvre and some
perhaps an attention djsdf along with
your meal and entree of attention oh she
got it no one had ever heard of this
woman before and now now we've mentioned
her name
there are plenty of people who agree
with her
at least plenty of people who say that
they agree with her and
this poses an existential threat to the
Republic as we talked about at the very
top of the show today
we now need
in Texas school districts we need
children to present government-issued
notarized birth certificates to join the
school choir
because social trust has broken down so
much and common language is broken down
so much and Community has broken down so
much
and this would be another example of
this
polybius has a good observation the
ancient Greek historian of Rome who
pointed out that democracy can persist
only when there is a reverence
for the gods only when there is
a serious disciplined limited behavior
only when there is respect for parents
and elders and we talk a lot about how
how democracy and republics are built
for moral and religious people only so
there's your reverence for the gods we
talk about how people need to be able to
control themselves or government's going
to come in and control them more
heavy-handedly
sure that's true we don't we don't talk
enough about respect for elders and why
you have to respect your elders
uh politically that is one is to have a
stable Society two it's to preserve the
basic unit of society the basic
political unit which is the family
uh and three because it's what connects
Society through the generations the
older generation cares for the younger
generation
the younger generation owes reverence
and respect for the older generation if
you hate your parents
you're going to hate your country
because your country was built by your
forefathers a friend of mine a very
perspicacious friend of mine I've used
that word a lot recently it keeps coming
to mind maybe because of all these
incisive visions that keep popping up a
friend said that all of liberalism can
be boiled down to F you Dad
that's that's all you need to know
forget John Locke forget John Stuart
Mill John Rawls a lot of Johns among the
Liberals throw all of their books out it
doesn't matter all you need to know
about liberalism is that it boils down
to
F you dad and that's what you see that's
what this woman is yelling about here
the blood in the streets
awful place because all of my forebears
and forefathers were bad and I hate you
Dad and this is terrible and this is the
the liberal view of History
the past was bad the present is a crisis
the Utopia is right around the corner
but we've we've got to urgently pursue
progress and it it rips up everything on
which your Society previously had
relied
that's it if you don't if you got if you
got Daddy Issues that's not just a
personal problem that's going to bleed
over into a political problem as we see
today right now go to
grillblazer.com Knowles thanks to our
friends at Grill Blazer instant barbecue
Perfection is at the touch of your
fingertips Grill Blazers Grill guns are
designed to do everything from expertly
searing your Meats to lighting charcoal
grills wood stoves outdoor fireplaces
and just about anything you can think of
where you would need high power fire to
solve your problem I may or may not have
sparked up a stogie with a grill Blazer
gun you may have seen that grow Blazers
offers two types of Grill guns the grill
gun basic is a high power propane torch
designed to Light charcoal and wood
grills and smokers burns up to 3 600
Degrees it's 30 inch flame is pretty
much all you need a big bad torch to do
and then there's the SUV gun shorter
Barrel perfect for professional Culinary
Kitchen uses from gently caramelizing
brulee or other sugars and fruits to
rapidly searing stay takes outside on
the grill warning the grill gun will
result in extreme Grill Envy from your
neighbors right now go get the grill gun
from Grill Blazers go to grillblazer.com
Knowles use promo code nulls for 15 off
your order grillblazer.com Knowles promo
code Knowles for 15 off your order now
speaking of insulting your audience as
this woman has
Fox stock
has been downgraded Fox News
dominant name and cable news has been
downgraded after
the viewership has continued to decline
Wells Fargo downgraded the fox
Corporation stock
is Fox news's viewership has not
rebounded since they fired Tucker Tucker
who was their biggest name and actually
the biggest name in the history of cable
news in May ratings for Fox took a
nosedive because they kicked out Tucker
the Network dropped from a 3 million
viewer average to a 1.65 million viewer
average in the 8 PM hour it's almost 50
percent drop
and they haven't really rebounded so
Wells Fargo is deemed Fox Corporation
underweight because Fox News drives so
much of the profits of of the fox
Corporation and uh now with ecosystem
risks also elevated Wells Fargo finds
the estimate Outlook more negative and
below the street below Wall Street okay
Fox might not be able to ride this one
out
previously
the corporate understanding of boycotts
was that boycotts usually don't matter
all that much if they do matter at all
they're going to matter from the left
because the left has the institutional
power and so if if the libs call for a
boycott
they'll probably cave at least to some
degree and then everything will be fine
if the conservatives call for a boycott
it doesn't matter conservatives are not
sufficiently organized they don't have
sufficient institutional power
so ride it out you wait a week Bud Light
sales are going to increase again okay
you wait a week the conservatives are
upset that that the main conservative
host left at Fox is gone okay but
whatever in a week or two they'll come
back they haven't come back
they haven't something has changed here
two things have changed actually one the
the
political landscape has changed there is
a populist movement and there are
greater platforms for populists to speak
and there has been a flattening of of
the Public Square which the big Tech
platforms are doing their best to
counteract by censoring conservatives
but then you see chinks in the armor you
see a
an open-minded if not conservative at
least non-leftist like Elon Musk he buys
Twitter conservatives get to speak again
you see people cutting cords and pulling
out of traditional cable to begin with
you see conservatives recognizing that
the uniparty establishment doesn't serve
their interests either in its Republican
form or its Democrat form so you're
saying Alternatives pop up people like
Donald Trump taking over the Republican
Party even though Trump has no
particular Affinity or loyalty to the
Republican party and then the other side
of that is that the corporations even
the supposedly conservative ones
have become more liberal Fox made an
intentional choice to become more
liberal to fire its most prominent
conservative host to get rid of a lot of
other conservatives on the platform to
Blacklist conservatives from the
platform to to indulge in radical
leftist ideologies even in the very
language that they use and they they
just thought that they could get away
with it but there's just sometimes you
reach a bridge too far and
for it because we're still on YouTube
right now I'll speak uh Ambiguously
back in the 90s the social ideologies
and movements
they didn't push the conservatives too
far conservatives didn't like it but
they didn't push it too far in the 2000s
didn't totally push it too far even in
the early part of the 20 teens didn't
push you too far
but they reached a point on some of the
social stuff
where a flip just switched
or if a switch just flipped or a switch
switched I don't know and
parents said no more and Suburban voters
said no more and cable news viewers said
no more and beer drinkers said no more
and the corporations are waiting for
that bounce back I hope they don't hold
their breath boy what a great clip that
was it was great I know I know well if
you want more of them and if you want
long form interviews and if you want the
yes or no game if you want all the show
and if you want everything you gotta
ring the bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time